So today I'm gonna
make a presentation
about complexity and more
specifically tailored,
towards like
around visualizing
graphs because this
is a conference
about graphs. But this,
format is gonna be a bit,
different from what,
you're used to,
I think, because
I want to make
a presentation and and to be
very interactive,
meaning that I will
ask, questions.
And depending on
how you choose
to answer, we will go through
one or the other way.
So it's very easy to do.
Basically you just go here,
you can scan if
you have a phone,
it's even better.
You can just either
you can join
slido dot com and
you put the data
art as a hashtag
or you can just
scan it with your phone and it
will automatically join.
And so it's pretty
cool because
you will see that the results
as you vote,
are completely integrated in
the presentation.
So it's it's pretty
cool as a as
a feature. And I will ask you
just to make sure that you're
ready and to know
a bit more about you.
You this is the one
what it looks like.
Ask a question,
and you can see on the left,
you can always join,
the present,
like the presentation
and the polling
part. And so this
is like a question
because we're gonna talk about
visualization and especially
around graphs. So it's a good
idea for me to, you know,
try to adapt also
the content and see,
as you can see here,
we would see in real time how
many people vote.
And it's cool because you see
people are fighting.
You can also edit your answers
as we will go as
we will see in
the in the next slides
if you want to,
you know, go back and forth.
So we have eighteen people out
of I think fifty three.
So let's let's get
everyone, you know,
get everyone on board And in
the meantime, so, yeah,
this presentation
is really about,
data art and I'm
not really sure
if you're familiar
with the field.
So I'm gonna first try to
introduce what is data art,
the difference between data
visualization and data art,
go through different
example of
graph visualizations.
And, if you have time,
if you are nice people,
we'll also go towards,
another kind of work that I do
with more with
with ai which is
about neural networks.
It's not exactly
a knowledge graph,
but it's still
around networks.
So it makes sense
to talk about
this here and at the end also
have another surprise.
So, let's try to have
a bit more people.
We have twenty five people.
You can just join us.
Go here on the website,
put the hashtag or
just scan here,
the the QR code
with your phone,
and then it's automatic.
It's gonna be refreshed
automatically.
You don't have
to do anything.
It's just, it gets automatic.
And if you're not,
if you don't have
time to join now,
don't worry. The
next question,
you always have
this left panel
so you can always
join in and,
you know, participate.
So from what we
have right now,
we see that most
people so you,
you dabble, right?
So, you know,
about database and
some people like really,
like seven percent
of, of people,
people really like my life
revolves around data
and visualization.
So you guys are
really expert,
but, for most people I think
it's going to be pretty new.
We know I have an idea of what
database is and,
but we want to know more.
So let's, let's begin,
just to quickly introduce,
who I am quickly.
I have a background
in data science and,
I also, and are like switched
after my PhD in more into data
visualization. But,
today I'm going to go and talk
about data art,
which is something
that I've been,
like doing for, I'd
say seven years now,
professionally. So I basically
earn money selling data art.
This is, like, the definition
of professional. Right?
And, so this is gonna be we're
gonna be focused
about the work
that I did on on data art and
and then it relates
to, graphs because,
I did my PhD in graph
visualization,
basically. So it's
gonna be very
well connected.
So I just wanted to introduce
how I really
started, you know,
to, play and and, you know,
work about data
visualization.
This is an actual
picture of my
board back in the day
and you know,
people were asking me, hey,
what are you working on?
You know, this is
like the classic.
If you do, like, a thesis,
people ask you that
all the time.
And I was very naive at that
time because I thought people
were actually they were really
interested in
knowing the answer.
So I was like
going go straight
to the board, trying
to get a look,
this is what I do.
And then I realized
this was just,
you know, they were asking me
just out of courtesy.
So I was I was like
a bit frustrated,
but I realized, okay,
maybe if I could,
you know, try to
visualize what I do,
people will get
more interested
because you know,
you can see it and it's not
about math or code
or anything.
So this is how I
started and get
interested into the field of
data visualization itself.
So what is database?
Basically, if I
were to, like,
an outline of three points,
database is about to,
it's to be the most efficient
effective in communicating
statistics or
objects or numbers
in a visual manner. Right?
So the keyword here
is to be effective,
which is different
from data art.
So you want to
have to minimize
the time it takes for other
the audience to
understand what
you see on the screen.
For instance,
here we see a map
with dots, we see bar chart,
a line chart. And just by,
looking at the legend
or the the title,
like the description
of the chart,
it should get pretty it should
be pretty easy to
understand what it is.
This is the goal
of database to
communicate, but
also to explore.
If you work if you
work as a scientist,
you you have no you
have a big dataset.
You have no idea
of what it is.
You're gonna start
by creating some,
you know, basic charts just to
get your hands on the data,
understand what what's
the distribution,
the length, the size,
the clusters and so forth.
So it's a very good
tool to explore.
But basically all in all,
the point is to develop one's
cognition about
the underlying dataset.
So this is like my definition
of database.
Now if you know a bit
about database,
you can, like look up on Andy
Kirk's like website.
Yes. Yes.
Like I don't know,
six hundred different tools,
like everything
that is related
to data visualization.
Most people here
will be familiar
I think with the tableau or
power bi or click
like there are
three main competitors
in this space.
So So basically,
if you're not really familiar
with database, you
take the tool,
right? You go, here,
this is tableau,
you have your data,
you drag and drop
on columns row up,
you have a chart
pre made for you,
you try to color,
you put the time
and that's it.
You are doing data
visualization.
So why do we need
to go beyond?
Why do do we even care about
creating custom
data visualization
when you have like
good software
that do it for
you automatically
and very efficiently.
Well, all in all,
it comes to impact.
If you do like
dashboarding all
the time, it's
difficult for people,
you know, to have
something like
to remember the visualization
to be remembered by because it
they all look alike.
So what if you
work in database,
you're striving for impact.
So you want to be impactful so
that the message that
you communicate,
the story that you
tell, you know,
helps people, take this new
decisions or
reason about their
businesses and so forth.
So if you want
to have impact,
what do you do in general?
Some people, you know,
they go on the street
and they protest.
I come from France.
This is our specialty,
as you all know.
So then when they
go on the street,
they try to protest
to influence people,
right? This is one way, I'm,
I'm trying to do
the other way.
So this is supposed
to be a mirror
and I'm more,
you know, maybe,
you know, Michael Jackson,
man in the mirror song.
I'm I'm think if you want to
like influence people,
it has to come from within and
to do that,
what better way than
using art to do so?
Because art is very subjective
in its nature. So if you can,
if you're touched by a piece,
you can really, you know,
it can change your the way of
thinking and how you perceive
life in general.
So instead of
doing the protest
because I'm alone,
I cannot really
organize anything.
Maybe we should try to go more
on the artistic routes because
it's less frightened,
frightening.
It's very deeply personal and
you can have a greater
greater impact.
So this is basically
how I, you know,
started and doing
data art and say,
okay. Maybe if I
can do a piece
and I can have more impact,
then my goal is complete.
And my goal being
as a scientist,
try to communicate science,
make people understand
complexity,
such as, like like,
understand how graphs work,
the connections,
and so forth.
So this this, like,
was the whole
motivation here,
and we're gonna
talk about this.
So, basically, if you look at
at this particular piece,
you have no idea what it is
because there is
no description.
And, but you you
believe me when
I said that this
is based on data.
So what is data art?
If we are to, you know,
give a definition,
data art is not
data visualization
because the goal here,
the most important part is to
create emotions.
So first and foremost,
you want to
maximize emotions.
And hopefully for instance,
if you see the piece
here on left,
you want to get closer because
maybe you like the colors,
maybe you like the shape.
But as you can
see below here,
you also have
a description and
this is where
the artistic message
comes. So in some pieces you
have no description at all and
it's up to the viewer
to understand
what's what's really
happening here.
Data art is different because
it is based on data.
It has a more objective truth
than the solar arts.
It's imagination.
Right? So basically you get it
attracted by the colors,
the shapes,
so forth. Then you
read the description
and hopefully you
reflect on yourself.
This is how the message
gets to you.
And all in all,
back to the same thing that we
have in database,
we develop cognition
about the underlying
dataset,
the scientific principles
and other types of things.
So this is basically
my definition
of data art. I
hope that it was
clear the definition between
database and data art.
And you could you
could like, you know,
ask me, okay, why are you are
you the only guy
doing this data art?
And I'm not.
This is from a paper from back
in the day two thousand and
seven on the database
conference.
You showing
the merits of doing
artistic data visualization.
So this was, like,
something that
people noticed,
like, even even before that.
But, you know, trying
to understand,
explain that if
you put emotions,
you have a greater impact and
people find the charts or like
the images more memorable.
And so it's actually a good
thing to have
visual embellishments
even though it makes maybe
sometimes the data a bit less
clear to perceive
at first glance,
but because it has a greater
impact and they
can measure that,
all in all, it's better.
So this is how I try to also
connect the artistic
part with the,
like a field of
research as well.
So if you are
interested, you can,
look it up. But basically,
how how does it work?
What what is
the design process
to to create some
graphs and art
with graphs? For instance,
what it's very similar if you
come from a design
background,
this should be very familiar.
It's exactly the same
as database.
It's gonna be interactive,
meaning that it's
not like, oh,
I have an idea.
I'm gonna work two weeks and
then that's it.
It doesn't work like this.
It's sometimes
the most frustrating
part is, like,
sometimes in two hours,
you have you have you actually
have the final design,
but you spend three
weeks refining
the thing just to go back to
the first one
because the client
likes it. So it's
it's iterative.
But the question
that you have,
you ask yourself is like,
are you going to create
a static piece,
like an image? Is it going to
be animated? Maybe it's going
to be a video. Is it going to
be an interactive
data visualization
or data art piece
so people can
click or have like sensors to
make it move in real time?
Is it gonna be abstract
or figurative?
What are the different shapes
that you can play with?
What are the dimensions that
you're going to
take in the data,
the clusters, the different
techniques and have to strike
the right balance
between order
and chaos. So exactly
the basically,
I would say the the things you
have to take into
account and colors.
Of course, people like to do
black and white. I
like to do colors.
So, and because it's data are
they have to mean something.
So if they have
the same color,
they should belong to the same
cluster for instance.
And, so they have a mean.
So, basically, if
you had to say,
like, to describe
my job in one
side would be
data, some code,
and basically you
create a visual
that that that
means something.
I hope that it's like one data
art in one side.
This would be it.
So now I wanna go
back to the example
that I showed before,
and this is about the Montreux
Jazz Festival,
one of my favorite
examples. So if you're not
familiar with
the Montreux Jazz,
this is one of the most famous
music festival in
the world in Montreux.
Montreux is in Switzerland.
And, just to give
you an idea,
it's pretty big
as a festival.
It has been going on for more
than fifty four years now.
And is that it has
eleven thousand
hours of videos with
different cameras,
six thousand hours of audio,
more than a hundred
thousand pictures,
but and, basically,
the dataset is two point seven
petabyte and, like,
spread across two different
dataset cooled by the water of
the Lake Geneva.
So this is like
the the data we have to,
play with, which
pretty big. Right?
And basically
what I I tried to
make some
visualization to give
you an idea of
what you have in
the dataset. Here,
each dot here is
an artist that
played at the Montreux
Jazz, with this,
his location, its location.
And you see that the the notes
here have different shades.
They're more, like,
the more purple you are,
it means that
the more connected
musically to
the other artists.
So you can ask,
how do you compute the musical
similarity between artists?
And to do that,
we have to analyze
the sound itself.
And remember that
mantra is a whole
new setup. It's
not the same as
the studio version.
You have to analyze
the rhythm,
the melody,
the notes, chords,
harmony, things like this from
the reading, the signal,
then try to compare
songs together
and see if this sound alike,
and then grouped
all these songs
by artists. And
this is how you
get artistic similarity,
which is pretty cool because
people have been using this
particular map, for
ethnomusicology.
So to understand
the origin of music,
for instance, here
would be Bikin,
which is the most
famous festive,
like, musician
and the jazz and
see how he influenced
with blues,
you know, other
people that came
in the festival as well.
So this is an example
of a database.
This has nothing
to do with art,
but just to, as
I said before,
to give you an idea of what,
what is the dataset,
and then we progressively move
on to the more artistic part.
Another visualization
that we have,
this is about the evolution of
musical genres over time in
the Montreux Jazz.
So as you can see here
at the beginning,
it's like the the curve
is really
narrow because we
only have, like,
the festival was
basically three
days in one, like venue.
But at the end
now it's supposed
to be fifteen days in three
different stages.
So we have more in terms of
volume and more songs,
getting played each day.
And what's also
interesting here
is that the proportion
of jazz,
which is the pink
one in the middle
is more or less
constant over time,
but we add more
and more different
musical genres.
So it's not about
jazz anymore.
Even like back in the day,
as you can see,
you have hip hop,
reggae, metal,
electro and so forth.
So it's really like a very
international music festival
even though it's, you know,
it's dead centered
around the the jazz.
So this is a bit
more abstract.
This is called a stream graph
as a visualization,
and it shows,
like, the evolution
in time with
the width being
proportional to
the number of songs.
And now we I want
to go back to
the image that
you saw before,
the very which is
about the artist
of the jazz itself
connected if
they've been playing
together on stage.
So basically you
concatenate and
you you flatten all
the concerts in one dataset.
And because, you
know, artists,
they tend to come
several times
at the Montreux Jazz and each
time they come,
most of the stars,
they come with a new lineup,
a new bassist, a new drummer,
a new singer,
sometimes if you're
like a guitarist
and so forth.
And so you can connect
all the different
artists of the jazz
if they play
together, on stage
at a certain
point in time.
And this is what
we had here. So
this is like a very
nice, simplified schematic,
but if you scale
it to the, like,
whole dataset, not
the whole dataset,
but like the most interesting
part at the center,
you would see here,
all the connection,
the big yellow dot
here is Vivi King.
You have Santana
here and George
Duke and you see
that all the lines
seems to converge
at the center.
And it makes sense
if you think
about it because the artist at
the center are mostly jasmine
and blues men because
it's the montage
jazz, but also because
the music itself,
you know, calls for
collaboration,
you want to jam
with other people.
So if you're a Jasmine,
you will change you.
And each time you will come up
with a new quartet quintet.
And this way you have,
you get very connected
at the center.
So all the lines seems
to converge here,
and you can be very popular as
an artist. And
I've just played
here in this small
cluster with
your band. But if you didn't
really mix with
other artists,
you will not be connected
at the center.
So we have this,
what we call the Montra
jazz galaxy.
The whole piece
was called jazz
luminaries and it was
displayed in this,
full dome. So it's
like a small,
very small planetarium.
And we also, created this
controller here,
which is actually
a phone inside
where you can, you
know, play around.
So it was interactive.
You could select an artist.
And when you click
on the artist,
see all the different concerts
and then listen to
all the songs.
So imagine being
able to listen
to more than two point seven
petabyte of data in
your fingertips.
So it was pretty cool
as an experience.
I want to show I I
can only show you,
like, part of
the video because
everything is
copyrighted as you
can imagine, but it would
basically look like this.
People will, you know,
lay on the floor and have this
weird controller.
And as you will
move it, you know,
in space, you
would create this
fisheye effect and
on the three d,
like graph that you see here
with all the different,
pictures.
And then if you click
on the the most,
the selected note,
you would see that everything
will slide and
all the different
concert for this
artist would come up.
Then you click on the concert
and you'd be able to browse
the different tracks.
So this is,
I hope that I
know it's a bit,
underwhelming
because you cannot
see the whole experience,
but I hope that
you get the idea
through this, like,
smaller video.
So this is, like,
the the the two d,
render of the three
d mesh that
we we saw before.
And then what we
saw just before
the BB King stuff is we get
the center here.
I hope that, this example,
and it gives you a better idea
of what data art is and how we
can go from the the old data,
the data visualization,
and then create something
more abstract,
which has a story and and to
arrive to this
particular piece.
But now I want to get back to
what I said at the beginning.
And I said at
the beginning that
you were there here, right?
So maybe you
recall those books
back in the day where
you, you know,
if you want to make
this decision,
you go to page eighty
four and then you,
you turn left and you die.
And most of the time you have
to go back to the beginning
of the book,
but we're not going
to die here today,
but you are going
to be the hero,
meaning that depending on what
you choose, we will go through
one of the other
different artworks.
So you are in control of
democratically of
what we can do here.
So I will first ask
you to pick a shape.
So I'm gonna ask
you this question
right now,
here and it should
appear on your phone.
And so let me and to make sure
that it's true,
we can also see in real time.
So I'm not cheating.
You can see that
you can change.
It's up to you.
So we have thirty seven people
voting beforehand.
So let's, let's
try to have a bit
more today. And now in this
particular question,
what's really funny about this
is that depending
on the demographics
of the crowd, you
have different
choices. I give one of, like,
kind of this talk
in the US and
in Europe, and
it's it's always
different. But
Square, you know,
just really seem to be, like,
no one likes square.
Either a circle or a triangle
and you see people
are fighting.
If you if you're
at a square and
you feel alone,
you can also edit your answer
and choose one or the other
because sometimes
you have like
a it's a perfect match.
So I have to choose
it randomly.
It's not not
because I said that
square has no love.
People are gonna going back to
edit the answers
and and, you know,
changing and go
back to square.
So this is really,
you understand
how politics work
politics work, right,
with this kind of line
voting and stuff.
So okay. I think so.
Circle and triangle.
So if none of
the square, okay.
Triangle is a bit better.
So let's go with
the triangle.
So sorry for the circle.
Sorry for the square.
Let's talk about this one.
So if you look at this
particular image,
basically, you have
no idea what it is.
Exactly the same story as what
we had before.
But what you can
already notice is that we have
different kind of cluster,
which seems to be
connected, but,
like, still well isolated in
different colors.
So this particular piece is
about papers,
papers and patents,
actually. And this
was a collaboration
with the professor at at EPFL
working on the in the like,
it's a knowledge
graph really.
And and this field of study is
basically knowing,
like, innovation,
how and how we
relate technological
products that we have,
like an iPhone or anything,
to the the research
that, you know,
originated from,
for instance,
papers back in
the fifties will
which led to, like,
transistors,
screens, and so forth,
and to have in the end
the technological
products that we
have in our hand.
So all the story of
how innovation,
you know, evolves in time.
And so basically,
sorry for the French here,
but what you see
here is a connection
between patents.
So if you have
a white, border,
it means it's
a patent connected
to papers. Because
when you file
a patent, you
basically need to
do the prior art
and, you know,
you can cite other
scientific papers.
So it's really interesting to
see how long it takes
for a scientific
paper to get in per
field, you know,
to get cited and how long it
takes to get patents.
Sometimes you have tons of new
patents which are
not connected
to scientific papers.
So you are really wondering,
is it really innovation?
Is it like a radical
innovation?
Is it a very well
kept secret?
You know, so you
all these kinds
of questions. And as
you can see here,
all the nodes are lined up
according to the time,
basically.
So the the last,
state the the last
story was is,
on the fifties and below.
So it starts really, like,
back in the day, I would say.
And here it's two
thousand seventeen,
I think.
So this is like the when I got
the dataset, basically.
And you can see here,
this is about
computer science.
This is electronics.
This is cosmetics.
And each time you
have a different,
I think, thirteen different
fields of research.
And you can see,
like, for instance,
computer science, you know,
sites more papers and that it
goes deeper here.
So So it has more ties to
scientific research
than cosmetics,
for instance, here or it's it
starts to vary like very this
is maybe the eighties and you
have tons of patents
and less papers.
And here, as you can see,
we have few white notes,
but tons of black
notes or black
borders. So it means that more
research than patents,
for instance.
So this is, like,
the kinds of,
like, knowledge that we can
extract from this particular,
not necessarily this
visualization,
but also the the dataset
itself.
It's really
interesting because
it is based on the the patent
office in Bern.
It's it has more than eighty
million patents.
This is, of course,
just a small subset where we
have we we actually
we make sure
to have also the link
to the scientific
papers, It's not easy to do
because you need to
parse, you know,
all the NLP natural language
processing to match
the authors,
the name, the themes
and so forth,
which is quite
difficult to do,
but really interesting as a as
a field of research.
So this is this
was one example.
Let's move on.
Let's take another
ask another question.
Now we'll ask you for a color
and you have to
vote, you know,
your favorite color
green, blue,
yellow or red.
And, according to
your choices,
we're going back to
the to the piece
that matches what
you chose and
talk about it again.
Blue is always,
one of the, like,
crowd's favorite. I
think I don't know.
It's okay. I don't want to
influence any of you,
but I think that
we have a clear
winner here with the blue.
So even though you can you can
still change your choices,
but I'm not sure
we're gonna talk,
you know, the,
the blue choice.
So let's go. Let's,
let's talk about blue here.
This one this one is actually
I'm not sure if it's
my favorite piece,
but I think it is.
So this one is a very
personal story,
for me. But once again,
just think about it.
You have, like it seems like
the nodes are so
small that you
don't really see
them anymore.
You only see the edges.
You see there's like there's
like a a cluster at the center
with blue and red.
And maybe you saw
this picture.
It was, quite popular back in
in the day. This one
is about Star Wars.
Star Wars before
eleven, you know,
the new episode
seven eight nine.
Okay? So we forget this and we
go back to the real
star wars.
This is about the star
wars character.
Basically, what
we did here was
to crowd, you know,
scrape Wikipedia,
which is the Wikipedia of Star
Wars and try to
extract the the
all the all the characters of
the universe. And maybe
you're not like,
you know, maybe you don't,
not a diehard star
wars fan like me,
but on this Wikipedia,
you have more than one hundred
and sixteen thousand
pages created
by hand by users describing
the universe. It's more like
forty years of, you
know, data of books,
video games, comic
books, series,
everything related
to Star Wars.
People that make
all the description
and so forth.
So it's really, like,
very complete as
an as an archive.
And why is it really
important for us?
It's important
for us as humans
because all the con the corpus
here is already digitized.
It's in English.
It's quite easy to,
you know, extract.
Where and but the thing is if
we can develop the tools
to, you know,
match the characters and how
they progress in in time,
because you have, like,
star wars era
spends over thirty
seven thousand years.
So it's pretty big
as a universe.
We can develop the tools and
then apply them back
to our own history.
But the thing is with
our own history,
most of the manuscript are in
ancient language,
who are difficult to to read.
They are not digitized.
So it's it's much easier to
start first with a fictional
corpus such as this one,
and then go back,
develop the algorithm,
and then try to apply them,
on our own history.
This was like the motivation.
But the real in truth,
the real thing is
because I love
Star Wars, but, you know,
I have to keep appearances and
say that this is
really for us,
but I love Star Wars.
So what you see
here is a whole
different characters.
And for instance,
at the center,
you have Darth Vader,
Luke Skywalker,
David Palpatine, Han Solo.
And in yellow here,
the yellow nodes
are the criminals,
which are actually very common
in the Star Wars universe.
You have Chabalahat.
And if you look at
his connection,
the he is mostly connected to
other villains.
So people from
the dark side of
the force in red
versus the blue one,
the blue guys, the republic or
the the jedi's and so forth.
So you have this, you know,
duality between light and dark
side as you can see here on on
the screen. Back in so when I
did this piece,
I think it was in two
thousand fifteen,
we had more than
twenty thousand
characters, but
now we introduced
new episodes. We have
the Mandalorian,
which is great,
with also new characters
and so forth.
So you can the the universe
expands as we
progress. Right?
And so we we could
redo the same
work and see how
the the the universe
would evolve.
So this was about Star Wars.
Now let's continue.
Another question.
This one is a bit tricky.
I'm gonna ask you
whether you want to,
you know, if you you feel
adventurous or not, and,
you feel like opening
a Pandora's box,
you know, I tried to come up
with creatives
and I and we see
people are, you know, they,
they want to risk
everything or they,
you know, they are
more careful.
Okay. I think
it's pretty clear
that you want to
see what's inside.
So yeah, I think
that there's no,
people are very,
you know, daring.
Okay, fine. So you're daring.
I wanna talk about
this piece here,
which, is also
about, you know,
knowledge graph.
And, this one, it's
it's interesting.
It was also made
for a company,
and this is about LinkedIn.
So this is what
you see here are
connections between people
connected on LinkedIn.
And it was really
interesting as,
insights because so basically
how you create this,
you go to your
connection tab,
you can now, everyone
can do this on.
You can export your data.
What I asked is, like,
the the people in the company
that were willing
to all of them
export this,
remove all the IDs and and and
the identifier,
like and try to
merge everything.
So we have, like,
the corporate network
of the people
working in this
particular company.
And what's what's
really interesting
is that we could,
you know, yeah,
let me ask you the question.
What do you do you think that
people are if you
work in the same
company, do you share the same
network more or less or do you
have your own network? Right?
It depends. You
would say maybe
if you work in
a big company or
international company,
you don't know
necessarily the same
people. But in this
particular case,
it was about, a digital agency
in Switzerland.
So I thought that
people were,
you know, in Switzerland,
it's quite small,
so everyone will
knew each other,
but it's not the case at all.
What you see here,
all the the the notes here at
the center are the people from
the company. And,
the notes that you
see at the outside
are their connections.
And what we are
really interested
in here is to see
how the percentage
of overlap. And we found out
that only six percent
of connection
were shared between
the employees
of the same company working in
the same sector
of activity Was
actually quite surprising.
I thought it was, you know,
everyone knew each other,
but it was really
not the case.
So in terms of story,
it was really interesting for
the company itself because now
you can say, look.
We we bring people
from everywhere
in Europe and each
time they come,
they bring their
own knowledge,
their own network.
And, yeah, let me
show you the proof.
Here it is.
We also analyze like,
like tons of different
stuff about,
you know, managers
and like very
something that HR would
love to to have,
and this is what we did.
But I think it was striking
visually to see,
we see all
the different members
and see all their
their connection
then that we don't necessarily
see tons of overlapping here.
You have some small edges,
but not that much.
Only six percent, actually.
So this was another,
interesting project
just to show
you the closed box was,
exactly the same network,
but the previous iteration.
So it was exactly
the same network.
But, you know, it's,
this is where I started from
this image and try
to, you know,
expand and to create something
a bit more crazy.
This is, I would say,
closer to what you
would have in,
you know, abstract
modern art,
and this is really
purely digital.
There's no doesn't
really have any,
ties to another
art or the older
art movement. So now okay.
As I said before,
I wanna talk now a bit more
because we I think
we have a bit
of time. We have,
thirteen minutes left to talk
a bit more about,
AI because, okay,
it's still related
to to networks.
Right? But it's also
very creative.
And I hope that
maybe I you know,
if I I can,
show you some
creative applications
of AI, it, it makes you wonder
how you can also explain that
to your clients
or other partners
because here we
all work in tech.
But if you talk about AI for
the general audience,
it's about,
you know, terminators and that
robots are gonna kill me.
I'm gonna lose my job.
And I want to
change this because
this is not entirely true.
And there's like
very good things
to talk about with AI, but,
and showing something
more creative,
you know, it helps
people, you know,
understand how it works.
And they are, as once again,
they are not frightened
by the technology
and they want to embrace it.
And I think that's
a message in
terms of impact,
it's much more powerful.
So something that
you're also very,
like, it's very common.
It's using
generative adversarial
networks, GANs,
to synthesize new images such
as this one. If you
go to this website,
this person does not exist.
Basically, each
time you refresh
refresh the page,
you would synthesize
a new face,
which is almost, like,
photorealistic.
Here, the hearing
is a bit, weird,
but I think new iteration,
if you get lucky,
you cannot
distinguish the real
from fake. So, basically,
you have a a network that
synthesize fake images,
and another network
tries to to
check whether this
image is real
or fake. And once
it's trained,
then the network cannot make
the difference
between real like
training data or fake data.
And this is where this is how
you can create some, like,
photo realistic image.
Now this is not
very creative.
This is about face synthesis.
So how can we use the same
technology to to
create something
more interesting?
I will first ask you to vote
whether you are more
a micro or macro.
So let's see.
Okay. If other
people will have
the chance to, you know,
change their answers or not.
Okay. Well, I think we we all
agree on Macron now,
so let let's go.
Now if I if I had
to tell you if I,
in fact, told you that
you can actually,
train a network on a thousand
different objects,
and then you can compose them
to synthesize a combination of
the object that you see.
Now that you have
this particular
image and you have, like,
a weight of fifty two percent
for a mask, a crab, gorilla,
space shuttle,
birdhouse, coral reef.
You know, all
these ingredients
that you see here,
you can combine them to and
synthesize
a combination of them.
So just look at all
the ingredients
that you see here
and trying to
imagine something.
I think it's gonna be
pretty difficult.
I'm not even sure
if you know,
I like I don't even know what
what this was or, you know,
But this is what
the the power of AI.
This is where we can use it as
a tool to, you know,
sparkle creativity and get
surprised by the results.
So, basically I
combined the old,
all these ingredients and this
is the result. And to me,
this looks like
a more like a macro
shot, you know,
of something that it's both
insectoid and our same
time, like plant,
you know, vegetable
or something
organic at the same time.
So you can create
very abstract
shapes as well. Right?
We saw like very
realistic faces,
but it's all about
the training
data and how you combine all
the elements. So this is,
this was a still image with
the different elements.
Now I'm gonna show you videos
and see how you
can evolve and,
you know, make this whole
animation go very smooth.
So but first, I
have to ask you,
you know, the drill.
Once again,
whether you're more
like the sea person
or land person.
Oh, it's funny.
You know, most of
the time, people,
like, choose the sea, but,
it seems like we have
land people here.
So you're more, you know,
far from the sea. So okay.
Maybe I'll let
you guys vote to
change your mortgage.
So let it is.
So I'm gonna this
is a it's a video
synthesized with AI.
So I'm gonna mute
myself and, you know,
pass the the the it has some
custom music made
for the video.
It's on YouTube.
You can also watch
this at the end,
like, on your own.
Try to to see if it works.
The full video is in four k at
sixty frames per second,
so it's pretty nice
as a resolution.
Let me try to to
play it to you now.
Alright. So this, video,
is called and
this animation is
called evade
evading confinement
or lockdown. This was created
at the beginning
of, lockdown.
So the idea was, you
know, to create,
surreal landscapes
and then move
according to your
mood, basically.
All of so the quality was not
really great, but,
if you watch it on
YouTube on your own,
I think that would
be much better.
But you see how
smooth the transition
were because you can really
synthesize all
the intermediate
image images that
you need just
by moving the weight
just a tiny
fraction. And and so that it
makes very nice,
animations over time,
which I really like.
So this was
an example of a video
made with AI.
This is like another, like,
the other choices
that you didn't
select. As you can see here,
you have the abiding
confinement.
This was projected on in Paris
in e p seven,
which is like a a hyperbar you
see on the on the wall.
So it's pretty
big and was more
than fifteen meters,
wide and ten meters tall.
And so it was that displayed
here for ten days.
It was pretty good, you know,
to have the also feedback,
people asking me
what it was about.
And, you know, once again,
doing my science,
work and talk about how it's
made with AI. You see it's
nonthreatening. It's cool and
technology and so forth.
And people were
really happy at
the end instead
of just having,
it's gonna replace you,
your job and so forth.
So I try to to
emphasize and and
show the positive outcomes of
technology instead
of, you know,
just pointing out to
to the negative.
So that this is like a small
video to to have an idea what
it would look like.
So but, yeah, to sit
in this piece here.
There was no sound, though.
It was a bit shame,
but, it's okay.
So another application that we
can create with AI is that now
we can get inspired
by the shapes
that are generated
by the machine and,
you know, going
back to inspire
the database part or
the data art part.
And this is what I did here.
You see, this is to me,
it looks like
a flower bouquet.
Right? But but it was really
inspired by it
because I saw my
network was synthesizing
these shapes.
And I I realized, okay,
maybe I should try
to, you know,
take this knowledge,
graph this network,
and try to change
it so that it
will look like
a flower bouquet.
And you can zoom in here.
Each dot is a person,
and they are are
connected to to their,
hierarchy to to their
boss, basically.
So this is about
a whole group.
This is like the global CEO,
and you have
the top executive,
and then you can actually go
down the hierarchy
to the intern
of the intern of
the intern and
at the top here.
And instead of
having, you know,
something top down,
I'm the boss.
You are my employees.
The idea here was
was as a CEO,
I let my, you know,
my what we do together makes,
we grow as, as a company,
but also as human beings.
So this is more like a flower
like shape instead of being,
something very hierarchical.
This was, like,
the artistic idea
behind the, the piece,
but it was really
influenced by AI.
So this is how to go back to
the to the knowledge
graphs and
so forth.
So I think we have
we have a bit
of time. I think
I want to show
you one last, surprise.
We have four minutes
because, you know,
what what have been presenting
so far is really
based on math.
Right? You have
either for deep
learning or visualization or
knowledge in itself,
knowledge graphs.
This is about, you know,
doing layouts and
stuff about math.
So I have a an example
to show you,
something that you are all
familiar with, I
think, in theory,
but you are maybe not that
familiar with
the recent advances
of of this. So I want to talk
about fractal art.
You know, this is like very
something that we
see quite often.
This is the Mandelbrot set.
So a fractal is
a shape made of
parts similar to
the whole in some way.
This is
the official definition
and fractals are
really omnipresent
in nature. It
could be in leaves
and your heartbeat
and crystals
and vegetables
and mountains and
snowflakes, like
everything is fractal.
So this is what
we have, like,
a standard modern broad set.
But the software that we have
now is really powerful and can
create very different
looking shape.
And to prove that to you,
I will ask you to, you know,
pick a side and choose whether
you are more like
an organic or
geometric guy and
and see if you
are surprised by the results.
So, okay.
So it's almost fifty fifty,
but we we can have
more people.
I think we can have ten more
people voting. So organic.
So you are very, like,
interested in knowing
how something so,
like, mathematic and geometric
could be more looks like more
organic maybe. So
let me oblige this.
This is a fractal.
This is pure math,
mathematical function.
And to me, it looks
like a virus,
you know, and it's was created
during the coronavirus time.
You can all, like,
see that it's
a fractal because
at the at the edges here,
you see that it
repeats and repeats,
it repeats, but at
the same time,
it looks very, you know,
around and something that you
could almost find in the,
under a microscope,
but it's just
pure mathematical
functions. Another
example here,
this called this one
is called a brief.
So it's about,
the virus as well.
And here, it's actually
data fractal.
So it was created five months
after the the initial
COVID you know,
announcement.
And you have five
ring one, two, three,
four, five rings.
And the cool thing about this
fractal is like
now we are almost
a year in the pandemic,
so I can,
you know, change
the camera and
create more and
more you know,
circle like shape like this so
I can actually
make it move over
time And to me,
it looks like,
you know, blood flow and kind
of like oxygen stuff.
So, this was the idea
behind the piece,
and I always try
to incorporate
some small data so that it has
more connected to
the data art realm.
Lastly, I want to show
you this example,
which is also a fractal,
but to me looks like more like
a sandstorm. And this was like
a three d render,
the three d fractal,
but the render
itself is almost,
grainy with particles.
And the old to me almost look
like like a sense storm,
something you would
see in the mummy
or dune or something
like this.
But once again,
this is just pure,
math. So I wanted to show you
the contrast
between, you know,
what we think a fractal is in
the Mandelbrot
set and something
we can which can
be very organic.
So to,
to con I have one
more video to
show you. And, so this one is
a combination of
fractal and, data.
So I'm gonna talk over it.
What you see here
is the fractal
that moves according
to the increase
of sea level,
and the data comes
from the NASA.
So as the sea level
rises, we see that,
the shape at the the center
starts to grow, grow, grow,
and if it grows too
much, then it will,
like, basically explode.
So this is what you see here.
And you also can notice that
camera itself seems like to be
zooming in and
out very slowly,
and this camera
movement is also,
matches the tide in France and
some particular dates.
So I try to
parameterize everything
that you see here according to
data and try to, you know,
use the this message
to, you know,
warn about the sea
level increase.
So something that
is we are all,
we're all in this together.
So this is what
the the main idea,
and as we go back,
then we smiled.
It's a fractal animation.
So this is my as
I said before,
try to influence both,
merge two ramps of
data and art at,
in, unexpected ways.
So to to conclude
this presentation,
I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask you one
last question,
and then we're gonna
maybe have time to,
to take some questions.
So basically just to let you
know that creativity
is the most
demanded soft skills of two
twelve twenty twenty and was
also the same, last year.
So if you are guys
are interested
to learning how
to do stuff like
this data art, I have
a YouTube channel,
and I also, you know,
you can connect with me on
different social media, and,
I'll be happy to,
to to talk it.
So to conclude art upsets and
science reassures.
I hope that you liked
this presentation.
If you have any
questions, thank you.
I think we have
some questions.
Yes. Kiran, can
you hear me? Yes.
Okay. Great. Yes.
We do have, unfortunately,
we don't have as much time as
we'd like to because
we're already
a bit over. But there is one
specific question
asked by Michiel,
who's also one of our speakers
that I just have to
address to you.
So, his question is,
how can a little bit of FARC
help in the process
of designing
commercial
applications powered
by knowledge graphs?
It's a very specific
one because
this is what he does.
So, he said that for
their customers,
it's often difficult
to imagine
that the different
types of entities,
allow different, and
new perspectives.
Do you have any advice on how
to trigger that?
It's a difficult question.
How can a little bit of I see
it in chat handling process of
designing. Well,
it's really about the message
you want to
communicate. Right?
So it's difficult
to automatize
the art creation part.
Unfortunately, I
don't I don't have,
like, a premade algorithm.
I click and it's beautiful.
But I think it it goes back to
the story, right?
If you can convey
a bit of emotion,
then your brain,
basically the knowledge graph
is read the left
side of the brain,
right? You about the logic,
rationality, and so forth.
If you trigger
hard in the right
side about knowledge
about emotions,
and basically you
combine both of them,
the feeling it's
much stronger.
So So you can use
that as a way
to convey that
your solution is
very interesting.
It offers new perspective
and so forth.
But, it's not easy to do.
We need to, you know,
hand it's something
as a handmade
for so far. Yeah.
That makes sense.
Okay. Well, we'll we'll
have to wrap up,
because otherwise,
we'll be eating into the time
of our next keynote,
which is also very
interesting,
which is done by Iran Avidan,
from Intel. So
our operator will
wrap up this session.
We'll keep your questions and
try to address
them to offline.
So thanks once again, Kiel,
then onwards with
the rest of the event.
See you. Thank you
very much, guys,
and I hope you liked
it. See you soon.
Cheers.